[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et depuis hier c'est la tempête du blé
qui balaie les îles britanniques les
hauts de france et l'europe du nord
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
du port de hambourg où une vague a
fracassé les vitres de ce ferry aucun
passager elle n'a été heureusement
blessé 20 secondes
[Musique]
asie on t'écoute parle bien fort qu'on
puisse s'entendre
avec son bruit du klaxon
parfois boire ensemble qu'elle fait ses
devoirs d'école avec la pandémie les
différents confinement et le télétravail
les français deviennent de plus en plus
sédentaire selon l'étude de l'agencé de
sécurité sanitaire 95 % des adultes ne
font pas assez d'activités physiques ou
alors reste trop longtemps assis mais
attention le risque de développer
certaines maladies s'accroît
d'avoir des expressions
non mais je vais écouter
non mais c'est mon pauvre etienne mais
pas ma pauvre lucette quand même d'abord
en plus c'est une expression que je
connais
dans les rues dans la publicité sur tous
ces formats dans la slow dans des
marques des communes et même des
institutions de la république l'anglais
est partout parfois auréolé d'un astérix
se renvoyant à une minuscule trad x tra
non alors déjà entendu traduction on va
pas chipoter mais alors la petite étoile
en bas des textes c'est un astérisque
astérix c'est le copain d'obélix mais
bon vive le français du 7e
mois je n'appelle pas ça des expressions
françaises mais ciani
c'est la première fois que j'entendais
cents cette réflexion enfin ce ce dicton
où cette manière de s'exprimer plus tôt
donc moi je ne connais pas ça je suis
complètement
hors de mon paysage avec qui les
français rêvent t-il de fumer un joint
il ya eu yannick jadot non en ce n'est
pas lui qui est en seine nord sanvignes
on joue avec eric zemmour eh bien oui à
16% les gens qui ont été interrogés
placent eric zemmour en tête avec 7 %
qui vous avez interrogé
en deuxième en deuxième c'est marine le
pen en troisième c'est aux gens de l'ex
que lee mélenchon et 1 % seulement des
français soient tués mais avec valérie
pécresse et nicolas dupont aignan
se concentre sur moi après sondage on
sent qu'il faut c'est un peu des choses
mais la france ben vi la france peut
faire une analyse politique de ça c'est
pas le genre ici ont
triomphé on dit n'importe quoi on est là
pour quoi évidemment l'analyse politique
c'est pas je veux dire c'est pas le
balto ici boire du café est très bon
pour la santé les personnes qui
consomment régulièrement du café vive
12% plus longtemps que celles qui n'en
boivent pas grande étude anglaise et une
par don du sang non non non non non et
fois c'est un peu aléatoire je vous la
corde là c'est quand même cinq cent
mille personnes ont été interrogées et
suivie sur une période de dix ans donc
c'est très scientifique universitaire
[Applaudissements]
enfin je vous rappelle mon étude préféré
sur le sujet est les suédoises elles
montrent que les femmes qui boivent plus
de trois tasses de café par jour ont une
poitrine plus peut-il que celles qui
n'en boivent pas là aussi c'est
démontrer mais les chercheurs n'ont pas
réussi à établir le lien je suis avec
rna depuis maintenant c'est la septième
année
je les ai rencontrés le 3 août 2015 j'ai
eu un coup de foudre direct sur internet
et moi j'ai pas réfléchi ça m'a pris
cinq minutes je savais même pas que ces
poupées existait j'ai
fait ou est ce que vous l'avez
découverte sur internet par hasard et
regardez bien la photo est un peu fou
quand on s'approche mais c'est brad pitt
est oui certes il arrive bien sûr que
ces branches et un masque aux femmes de
slips hilare boba 58 la baisse de l'irg
et voilà du dernier chic mais c est ça
franchement j'adore ce poste du centre
pompidou qui dit oui tu es poule mais et
tuent aussi cool que brad vis de centre
pompidou en parcourant quelques photos
de ses poupées
je suis à un moment tombé sur rna qui
avait qui n'avait pas cette période elle
avait des cheveux longs elle avait une
musette elle était assise sur le bord
d'une baignoire et j'ai eu un coup de
foudre mais direct cash
ça faisait à peine cinq minutes que
j'avais découvert l'existence de ces
poupées est bon je suis du genre à
acheter d'abord et réfléchir après
[Musique]
c'est d'havré telle émotion les chais je
suis dans les vestiaires de top chef il
c'est un truc douce qui est en train de
se passer c'est à dire que je vais faire
tester ma cuisine juste ici à des chefs
étoilés en fait ouais sauf qu'en
rentrant du plateau c'était pas un chef
étoilé qui l'a formé chez elle 1 mais
son mec et que c'était pas des patates
-qui le plus jeune
je suis désolé mais une amie de vivre ce
genre de saint valentin tu vaux de
l'aide non non non j'ai pas besoin des
deux
[Rires]
non mais ne me veut non j'ai pas besoin
de points voilà ici à part ça je fait
trempette et voilà
philippe risoli selon lui ces
millionnaires il faisait comme satan oui
traduit comme ça il s'étend sur micro un
[Musique]
as tu t'es là
le mouvement de libertin que j'ai créée
voilà je me suis lancé ce délire un jour
j'étais dans une boîte de nuit
libertines puis avec la patronne de ce
bar là précisément elle me dit mais si
tu te présenter parce que tu es écrivain
principalement libertin j'écris des
livres érotiques et libertin la fiche de
campagne et regarder la petite fenêtre
en haut à gauche ça c'est l'elysée
demain ah oui ah oui ça va changer
ça c'est mon projet le 3
pour lui point qu'en l'habitat urbain
s'allonge
[Musique]
vous pensiez que je l'avais pas vu venir
celle ci quand l'habitat urbain
s'allonge
[Rires]
des crises mémorielle des propositions
mémorielle et des partouzes ailleurs
mais les conneries aussi
[Applaudissements]